okay
all right all right welcome everybody
and
thanks for joining today it is june 9th
and we're here in actin flab math stream
number 3.1
with dobson safran knight prentner and
friedman
today is going to be a fun discussion we
hope that
you're also able to if you're watching
live ask us some questions because
certainly we don't have much planned and
would appreciate from that
feedback with you we're just going to
jump right into it and by way of
introduction
and welcome ask what is active inference
and how we got here we're going to go
around
and give just some initial conditions
initial thoughts
on these questions from wherever we're
coming from as we sort of converge on
this discussion
and then we'll just be writing down
thoughts and ready to
jump in and continue the discussion so
who would like to give a first pass
on either or both of these questions
i could try thank you adam go for it
um
so for me um active inference
is a normative
process theory for how
um a principle of what it takes to exist
the free energy principle or what it
takes to persist
can be realized and it's what are the
things you have to do
if you're going to have you want to say
to you
outsource your entropy or avoid getting
all mixed up
in the meat grinder of existence or
whatever what kind of intelligence what
kind of modeling
will you need to exhibit to do this to
and so in a way it's for me the answer
to the question of
what is mind um and potentially with
certain versions of it
uh what is life and with other versions
of it
what is consciousness and maybe even
what is free will
nice big questions and how did you get
here i have no idea
um i think it all started with an
existential crisis when i was young that
went on for a very long time
um but then i would say i found my
way to uh the architect
aka carl fristen um
when i was basically uh
through jeff hawkins book on
intelligence i learned about predictive
coding
and that was my on wrap to carl's work
and
rest is history awesome
so we heard some big general ideas what
is mine what is life
who else would like to go or i'll give a
thought
blue want to go for it sure i
am came to active inference through my
interest
in scaling so how do you scale
processes like at like from very small
like subatomic to cellular to organismal
to societal so that that was kind of how
i got
hooked into the active inference
framework
and and for me it's a framework um
that pretty it gives a pretty good
representation of how we tend to
represent and think about the world we
predict
we have feedback from like we predict
something will happen you know
if i turn the thermometer on the if i
turn the temperature up
the heat will go on so we predict that
we take the action
and if the heat doesn't go on we have a
surprise and so
it it you know we we then we go well
what what made our model go wrong
right like maybe my heater is broken so
it's kind of minimizing the surprise and
uncertainty
in our interactions in the world
awesome would either the two of you like
to go or
sure shannon do you wonder should i um
go ahead i'll go after you go ahead
okay well so i'm i'm perhaps
in some sense the outsider because i'm
not um i'm not doing research with
active insurance but
i'm a philosopher my background is in
philosophy and um
i think active inference is a very
interesting thing first of cour
first of course i like this big general
questions that adam raised at the
beginning what is mine what is life what
is consciousness and it's very close to
what i normally think about i'm a being
a philosopher i'm a bit skeptical
whether one could
actually answer this big question in a
very um
but that's a different story i think
active inference is very interesting
from a
philosophical historical perspective as
well because it kind of
um embodies um attention
um which ran through philosophy or
through the history of thinking
um which more or less started with a
very famous philosopher emanuel khan
with the distinction between an object
or
a world he called it the world in itself
like an outside world
and the way how we represent it and now
we can go
two ways from here one more one could
stay in this kantian
paradigm where the questions how do we
actually perceive
or are able to make representations of
the outside world
or we could go into the different
directions say oh
it's really about acting in this world
and active inference is a kind of
an interesting twist mix between these
two ideas
and my experience with it that some
thinkers
in the active inference camp they
tend to align closer with
or in the neocanteen tradition and the
other line of thinkers
they tend to align more closely to this
perception action
way of thinking so i'm very interested
in in this tension maybe it would be
to think about how it could be resolved
so
i'm i'm curious and how do i did i get
there
um like um well i
worked a lot with shanna here and china
basically
um got me in so yeah
thank you robert shannon go for it
yes um so right what is what's active
imprints so
um i too i'm probably more outside than
robert is i'm the math person here so
i'm just sort of off in the woods trying
to think about
like blue said how to scale all of these
theories so you have this formalism of
an activism
and uh you know inference based on sort
of discriminating between system and its
environment and i think that's uh
predicated upon a
kind of a very serious boundary argument
so i'm really interested in boundaries
i'm interested in also how boundaries
are predicated upon also
a possible holography theorem so
when we say you know um agent is you
know interacting with its environment
how does that actually work um
in a categorical way so we have a
venezianism probability
way but i'm sort of interested in how do
you do that categorically
and can you mathematize that even more
and sort of infinity categorify that
um perhaps like the definition between
inside and outside is
i think a very very beautiful one and uh
so how can we actually say that you know
what is represented in the outside is
you know the inside uh inferred
like what are the mathematics of that
also this seems to be happening
in a certain version of a simul
simultaneousness
so i'm really interested in the
mathematics of simultaneity and also
this sort of synchronic and diachronic
emergence sort of phenomena
so i think that what's happening also in
that i think the active inference
formalism is
dynamical enough to allow for these
sort of mathematical ideas to come in
and if you can mathematize then perhaps
you can answer these questions that
adam's asking what is consciousness what
is mine and those are those are the
heavyweights and that's i think that's
why you have the heavyweights of this
panel
as opposed like like for the question
how did you get here i'm trying to
figure that out myself
so i didn't know if that meant like
existentially or whatever somehow i just
kind of came online if you want to know
how i got like in this uh
interface i don't know and then um
but uh my very good colleague fields
gave a talk
and i sort of attended and i uh he there
so he was asked a math question and i
sort of answered it and then your
community like welcomed me so that
that's how i got here but i don't know
how i got here that makes sense
awesome thank you and yep excuse any
strange
noises in my background um
what is active inference i really liked
just a bunch of
pieces that people brought up robert you
brought up that
there's this action element this
pragmatic
turn uh looking at action and perception
in the world
and then right there the second word is
inference and that's that transcendental
or like a kantian type approach so when
i look at active inference i see
action and inference sounds a little uh
first level but those are the two pieces
that are coming together
which is traditions of action in the
world
and traditions of inference in the world
now as
compares with reinforcement learning or
other approaches to thinking about
agency and action in the world or other
economic
metaphors active inference diverges in a
few key ways
it focuses on the reduction of
uncertainty
rather than the maximization of for
example reward or value alone
so uncertainty reduction is a key
component of active inference
and also what adam brought up which is
the resistance to dissipation
and the characteristics of living
systems to be actively resisting
by making increasingly adequate
generative models of their niche
resisting dissipation and then also i
see active inference as a bridge
to disciplines and communities such as
systems engineering
or ecological psychology or embodiment
and so all these different areas that
relate in one way
to action and inference or to
philosophy there's so many roads that
come together
at active inference and that's a little
bit about
how i think i got here as well i
remember hearing about it for the first
time
from yella brunenberg who came on an
earlier stream
and it was a picture of i think a dutch
person
holding a cup of coffee and listening to
music and biking with one hand
and asking about this question of skill
and of action in the world
and just raising this provocative notion
that current models that we had for
action
planning weren't doing their job they
weren't able to explain that person on a
bicycle
so since then i've just been learning by
doing
so cool for this first question and i'm
sure we can return
back to it and ask more questions about
active inference
as we head on and of course anybody
who's watching live is
more than welcome to ask us a question
which i'll relay on
let's go to some of our questions that
we've thought about before
and this slide asks what is the role
of space in active inference
or in other areas that people are
familiar with working
and what is the role of time and then we
have that non-locality for both
space and time because
maybe we're curious about what
non-locality looks like in space and
time
so anyone's welcome to raise their hand
or
give a first thought danielle can i give
her a first thought
that was yeah yeah so in the
probabilistic setting and the
statistical mechanics that's the
mathematics that
fuels active inference right and before
you have me trying to come in and
categorify everything
um just for the active inference um kind
of experts in the crowd i was going to
ask you
um the role of space
like what is it so are you you know
modeling all of this on some kind of
euclidean sort of
uh manifold or are we looking at you
know something a little more interesting
so where i come from i'm sort of if you
really believe there's only now
then what does that actually translate
to so if we're going to take these sort
of powerful philosophies
of like you know if there really is no
future and you only act or the future of
some kind of potential that you only
actualize now
can you translate that for me into what
your space looks like so quantum
mechanics is working over
sort of non-archimedean space where you
have a very severe cut off
you don't have these infinitesimals and
things so
what like what does the space actually
look like for someone like
me who really believes that this sort of
in this interface is discretized
that every other nanosecond it does not
exist like whatever that means so this
whole thing
is a grand interpolation i just wanted
to know what y'all thought
about um in this inference model if
space is actually jagged and singular
or if you're assuming that it's some
sort of interpolated continuity
nice question adam you have a thought
there
um a few um
the
so most of my thinking has been in um
focusing on goal-oriented behavior uh
consciousness
agency pursuing goals and
this is in general the that's what i'm
gunning for and that's like
all questions end up getting filtered
through that for me but
um and
so for instance and i could see space
and time
uh in different senses showing up in
different
ways so um
a theory of consciousness i uh recently
proposed um i was suggesting that
we can think of it in terms of world
modeling but for this role modeling to
actually
be capable of um bringing forth the
world or being experienceable
it has to have certain um coherence
properties
and so i was thinking of con synthetic
operatory categories
as not just preconditions for judgment
space time
cause maybe some sort of uh unifying
minimal selfhood um but
these are also preconditions for any
kind of sense making whatsoever and for
the appearance of the world
people could object to that but um
then the question well what exactly do
you mean by space time and cause and
self
uh how much and what kinds and which
circumstances
and so for me space i tend to think of
it
more in terms of locality or there's
like
relative degrees of proximity among
things
and then uh there's
for time it would be things changing
within
space in a kind of proportional sense
like there's other senses of time like
you could have
some sort of like clock-like processes
that are like either in parallel and
coming to agreement or
like centralized and another sense of um
certain bottlenecks that force
a kind of temporal ordering um or you
could just thinking about like
things changing the things at different
uh rates there's
i think problematic circularity in what
i said but in terms of the senses of
space um
well i'll stop there but i could keep
going later no
cool just a few i guess basic
thoughts on space i thought about
embodied agents
and how an agent has a location in a
spatial
model so like the active inference paper
that we had where
different ants were at a different
location in space
now there's a difference between the
space that the actual physical thing is
in and then the model which kind of
relates to this
kantian distinction perhaps but even
when we have a disembodied agent there's
a state space
so i don't know what is the relationship
between a mathematical state space
and whatever you were mentioning there
previously and then as for time it just
made me think about the distinction
between
kronos and kairos where chronos being
like sort of a
metric or a measured time like a model
of time or something that's regularized
and then kairos being timeliness
and action happens kind of in both
action takes clock time
to carry out but also action has its own
time scale and actions have their own
sort of story arc
yeah blue go for it and then anyone else
who raised their hand
so space is something that i've thought
about a lot
um relative to like my previous work and
and i think about it a lot also in terms
of boundaries right
so where does one thing stop and another
thing
start um and you know like even
something so simple as like how do i
define like
my fingernail like where is the boundary
between like your fingernail and your
cuticle and anybody who's like really
dug in there like
there's some parts of your cuticle that
is you're like is this am i supposed to
cut this or what like
like so there's there's not a clear
distinction or
or line that can be drawn around what is
my
thing right and and so trying to find
this this distinct boundary
also in terms of inclusion in a group um
and
i listened to your last uh math stream
um
shanna and daniel and i was i was really
kind of um
thinking about this and i've been
thinking about cancer a lot in terms of
inclusion in a group um as you guys were
talking about that
and it's like i also think about it as
like a school shooter
like a cancer cell goes rogue like
they're somehow not included in the
group but they're not part of the
collective anymore and then they take on
their own like
self-interested agenda and i also think
about that like in terms of a school
shooter or someone that like commits
mass violence
and you know like when you have this
kind of you it's someone that's not
included in a group it's someone
that even is not included in like like a
rebel group like the al-qaeda or
something they're rejected from that
group also so when when they can't find
inclusion
they become like this rogue agent and so
so kind of i think about space as
as in where do you draw that line i have
a hard time
finding that space and it's something i
like to push on and then time
i don't really work with time too much
like actually per se other than like i
have to deal with like this
linear time that we're trapped in but i
do think about expansion and compression
of time
relative to age so like as a young
person like time seems to be so expanded
like five minutes is forever and as you
get older in life like a year just flies
by
right so so like as time it's it's
expanded as a young
person and then compressed as you seem
to age through life
thank you blue robert and sean
yeah thank you so much more of a
question than something
really interesting to say but it's a
question for you maybe
you can give me a good answer because
here on on this slide there's
the second world which is in parenthesis
which is non-locality
and i my guess is that jenna put it
there
and my my question would be whether
there is anything
that remotely resembles some notion of
non-local
inactive inference
to make that more concrete my impression
when i when i read articles by people
who
endorse active inference or work in that
area is that they usually
work against a very classical notion of
space and time as a background
so you mentioned the ants that move in
physical space
and that's usually assumed to be a
classical one or if you
i don't know if you if you think about
the cell
and you apply apply the concepts to a
cell then you say okay the molecules
it's a classical thing so there's no
notion of non-locality there
i guess i don't know um and my question
would be
um how whether and how an active
inference could accommodate some notion
of non-locality
nice question we can definitely wonder
and come back to that um
shauna and then adam yeah
um thanks yeah so just to get to the
time part because i
hadn't talked about that so thanks blue
for watching the last stream
i'm really fascinated by time and i
don't think my time really works linear
it's really hard to say like
uh where is yesterday you can do this
sort of
light cone sort of formulation and if
you want to general like
relativity it then you can say oh yeah
yesterday is in the light cone of
whatever you know so um but like what is
it and where is it so
when i asked like about the role of time
the thing that i'm sort of that i've
proposed in that fmf
um k theory diamond paper that i have
about
like the applications of all this stuff
of this higher category stuff
is to think that maybe time is more like
a pro time so in math you have this pro
object which is glued together from a
bunch of like um
morphisms and other collections of it so
it seems that if time is this
thing that is also emergent um i'm the
advocate that it's not
fixed right i'm also an advocate that i
don't really know how you measure time
without constructing it
so i'm not sure that we're actually
constructing a notion of now or does it
actually exist
so an active difference since you're
constructing you know every
every second of whatever every unit of
time
um you know how how can you actually
uh measure the inference without
constructing a parallel notion of time
like in the same thing
so like when adam's talking about
coherence and you know if you need a
coherence property for temporality
um to actually give you a singular now
or something
what does that actually look like so
robert's right that was me that put the
non-locality in there
because we we have like a rough idea of
the non-locality of space you can have a
two-point perspective of space something
like
uh you know my if in my state where i'm
i'm not like an entangled pair of
photons i can
clearly say oh silver lake is over there
and i'm in my
condo on the other side there's a sort
of separated distance but
according to a pair of entangled photons
there is no separated distance
and so you have a two-point perspective
of space so as in the mastering that i
did last time with dana we were you know
trying to figure out
is there actually a two-point
perspective of time can you actually
be a macro system and say that this is
purely non-local so i really i really
like robert's questions saying where is
the non-locality
i'm trying to build that into the very
mathematics of the thing
um of trying to categorify this awesome
formalism
but yeah so just time i think is it's
very strange and i think it's something
that we should all probably try to
try to tackle instead of assuming that
it's always there it's just some
background phenomena but
if time is emergent and space is
emergent also
then it sounds like active inference is
the right dynamical formalism that could
actually
you know kind of help that too because
maybe the agent is also making
time at the same time that it's making
you know um a world thanks
yeah we've seen active inference models
where at each time step
of the model the agent does like a roll
out
through the future that's called
sophisticated active inference
and then also it's a great point about
the multiple reference points we have
two eyes at different spatial locations
and that's how we infer depth which
isn't just a feature of the world
because it's something that we
have to infer and therefore it's
susceptible to optical illusions
and then the question with time do we
have a monocle we only have one
reference point on time
because then we're going to be just
totally unable to calculate depth
or if we can calculate or experience
temporal depth
does that entail that we're having
multiple reference points in time
so adam and then anyone else
so try to bring a few threads together
um
so some of the top what i'm really
liking
um about what blue and sham are just
saying
is this sort of um relational realism so
instead of saying like
you know what is time what is space
period
um well what is it relative to what and
then
um what is it and when i say coherence
coherence relative to what
um and so
and let's kind of backtrack some
um
in the kantian issue of like is it that
or just interacting
and and or is it that we're modeling
and the modeling is just a kind of a
pretense that's useful
for describing this like sea of forces
and that
goes beyond description um i think we
can have both
uh and so what i tend to do is view
interesting
systems um in terms of an active
inference also like
you have nested markov blankets and you
have nested
kind of nested hierarchy of dynamics
and so you could think of for instance a
set of coupling
uh processes some sort of chaining
together of dissipative systems
that manages to stitch itself you know
hold the cell together
through the way it's chained and this
could couple with the world
in a way that doesn't require
necessarily there might be like an
implicit
representation to it if you want to use
the word in that way of like a
correspondence between the dynamics
and like what is evolving
um or you could
that's like but it's not necessarily it
may not be inference in the sense of
like
the model like whether you want to say
that this modeling process is is
real or a way of viewing things that's
it's a matter of perspective
but then as you add layers of complexity
then you can get things like um
inner loop processes that could
refer to this set of kind of
action relations and bringing things
together and then you could even maybe
have on top of those
or within those another process which
points to
those so graphs pointing at graphs
pointing at graphs and so like
shannon's like category theoretic
perspective would be very relevant here
um but and so at some levels you might
talk of things like representations in a
cartesian sense like in good
old-fashioned cognitive science we may
have those
and we have an activist intelligent
coupling where it's just implicit
representation and maybe we shouldn't
even use that word
or maybe we should use that word i'm not
going to say
but i think we can have it all and so
the
um way that you think like space and
time
um from these nested systems i think
there could be in a way a kind of
non-locality and that they would be
evolving
independent like they're evolving on
their own time skills like a nested deep
hierarchy of dynamics
there's a sense which they're all kind
of brought together by virtue of like
sharing this markov blanket that they
ultimately agree so i guess
i don't know if that would be but
there's a there's potentially ways
that can diverge also and so it seems
like you could have maybe periods
of non-locality and locality and
actually this kind of going
in and out and probably butchering and
abusing the terminology i apologize
but this going in and out might even be
like necessary like necessary for a kind
of dual phase evolution for the systems
to couple
for them to like trade off their free
energy for them to
do what they do is this sort of like
iterative inferring their own existence
and
doing what they need to do process but
so within this view it seems like time
can show up
in multiple ways there's like the uh the
the time of just um
the world is a as this evolving graph is
a generative process in that way in
terms of if there's
um a kind of with it if
we narrow it in um to a particular
system like there's like some things
were before and some things were after
in terms of this
sea of causal influences but then you
might get another kind of time of this
psychological time
of you know spatializing time of
uh and then navigating through
spatialized time
and same things for space and then it
comes in again um
one more thing i guess i would say is uh
the issue of space and time
i think uh it's going to be
two things about that so one idea i'm
playing with is actually that um
our consciousness is actually the
spatial
kind of it in terms of visual spatial at
least it's actually always 2d
and that to the extent that we have
something like a 3d
awareness of space it's coherent state
transitions
of these 2d projections and there might
be
a relevance to holography there
that's one thing to put inside but then
one more thing would be
um and then you have maybe like a 3d
type space in terms of body space so
you'd have like a visual spatial
cartesian space and then like space
relative to the body
maybe like a kind of quasi-polar
coordinate space and between the two of
them
you can get a kind of like 3d spacing
coming out of this or or 4d space
because there's dynamics
yeah um but the one more thing about
um subsuming space and time to action
relative to what
is i think this will be crucial for
boundaries in terms of
what counts as a living system or not
and
what would count as a conscious system
or not of what kinds what are the
physical and computational substrates
of consciousness what kind of closure is
achieved on what scales
uh that issue i think um
so what i would like to have happen is
either
some sort of um definitive handling of
this some sort of like category
theoretic definitive handling
that would basically nail it hard
problem
solved schrodinger's question answered
unambiguous
or i want a proof that this is
impossible and then i can rest
thanks adam maybe robert was alluding to
this with the skepticism but for me
whether something is answered or not
it's a psychological story that
we're telling and you could be convinced
about something that whether it's proven
to be impossible or proven to be ruled
in
that would be a story and then also nice
about the
projective geometry we talked about the
projective geometry
paper some time ago about how we can
look at something like the corner of a
room
and even though the angles are going in
weird directions we kind of
infer it to be rectilinear so
that's pretty cool any um thoughts here
a quick thing in the projective geometry
actually um i
really love uh david rubroff's work on
that because it's like putting
it's a discussion of consciousness that
like puts
a person or puts an observer in
subjectivity
and interest like right at the center of
it
one thing i'm wondering about is
what is like the realization of this
sort of
projective geometric perspective engine
that he's thinking we have
um for spatial awareness um
it seems like uh there could be
like a sense that just that this is
something
the brain can do like there's some
proposals for something like this like
hinton has capsule networks
um uh numenta has like their thousand
brains that like
there is a kind of um
reference frame dependent modeling
happen happening in a distributed
way and that's part of the architecture
or they're just like somehow through it
it's it works as this graphics engine i
actually think it might be um
a more uh um an active type
thing in a string where actually the
reason
you get this projective um geometric
perspective capacity is because of this
coupling
between body space and visual space
linked by
different kinds of affordance relations
and that this is actually
part of what's letting you do these
state transitions
and do this kind of projective geometric
modeling rather than it being
baked in a distributed way like some
sort of graphics engine
but this is another way in which like
for instance um embodiment and interest
and value kind of other things get
subsumed to that
like thanks and
anyone can raise their hand just one
thought on that is action requires time
action is almost defined as a sequence
and then we have the policy variables
the pi
that's our kind of active lab pi because
policy is at the level above
a certain active state but action and
policies they do take time so there's
something time like built into our
models because
what we're talking about and the
inferring the state transitions just
like you described
all those are temporal and then the
non-locality
um it's kind of like when and drawing on
fristen's older work with dynamic causal
modeling and
statistical parametric mapping you have
an image of the brain
that's changing through time and then
you can make
one type of connected graph with pieces
of the brain that are anatomically
connected
and so when people think about space
usually that's what they're thinking
about things that are touching
but then also you could have effective
or functional connectivity
so you could have regions that are local
in
cause but that local link
in the causal network could be
due to some upstream factor that's
influencing them both
so causal proximity or functional
proximity
may or may not be the same as some
things that's
touching so not sure where they're
where that puts us but cool stuff
daniel can you say a little bit more
about like with regards to
what you just laid out with um um
action requires requiring time in the
minimization of surprise
so is there something in your in the
active inference formalism
when we say minimization of surprise is
there an agent that is
creating scenarios like dinosaur there's
no dinosaur in silver but they could be
a dinosaur i don't
want dinosaur so i'm going to act in
such a way as to preclude the very
possibility of dinosaur
right so when we say minimization
um where where is that coming from
so is that cut again is that is there a
profound
creativity that is the basis of this
system that is launching these
probabilities right because bayesian
probabilities
it doesn't like it seems kind of dull
right it never says that there's this
highly creative being
that is imagining these scenarios that
they wants to preclude
so can y'all tell me like where's that
coming from or has the agent seen
a dinosaur in you know in l.a walking
down the street and they go i don't want
to see that again
therefore preclude therefore action like
the action of
minimizing surprise requires time but
it's a diff it's an imaginary time
it's sort of like i don't want that to
happen again therefore i'm going to act
in such a way
as to preclude the very existence of
dinosaur does any of that make sense
well as for dinosaurs we know that
they're in the land before time
so that is you know clean and done well
something called scary minimizing
surprise you know yes
as for the minimizing the expected free
energy or
minimizing the surprise one of the sort
of tricks
of active inference is to condition that
upon a policy
if you look at the topology of the
graphical model
policies are getting um plugged into
the state transitions between hidden
states and then
what's being minimized is the surprise
of the sensory outcomes that are emitted
by the hidden states so at the first
pass without getting into this
like meta bayesian creative energy
the agent has a set of policies that it
can carry out those are the affordances
and then conditioning on each of these
policy options
if they're discreet like i could turn
left or turn right and then i'm gonna
do a conditional expectation on turning
left as my policy or
conditional expectation on turning right
on my policy
which one of those is going to in my
prediction of how that policy changes
the state transition matrix
what is going to result in less
surprising
sensory outcomes that is for a
sort of fixed set of policy options that
can be conditioned on
but it's a great question about how do
we go from the known
into the unknown how does the agent
learn a new affordance or maybe even
generate a new affordance internally
so there's probably a lot to be said on
that but one way that active inference
speaks to it is that when we focus
on action hand in hand with inference
we can think like how could the agent
ever navigate a new kind of physical
obstacle
like there's some kind of a wall that
you've never climbed before
but what has to be inferred isn't like
what's on the other side of the wall or
to the nth degree the details of the
wall it's enough to have a model
of bodily action and a preference for
being higher up and potentially
the affordances that the agent does
control it does know about those things
like the movement of the joints that
will help it deal with the unknown
because it's not just approaching
uncertainty as like something that has
to be
eradicated by determining exactly what's
out there in the world
uncertainty is something that's actively
negotiated with
through usage of the affordances that
the agent already has
right and when you say that are the
affordances constructed
are they conditions of the system are
they properties of the system
like what is the space of uh affordances
and is there to
like a topology on the on the
affordances because i'm still
like you know if we categorify any of
this there's a you know if you work in
two spaces or anything like this like
all you know um or in the in the
reflective subcategory which i always
talk about these objects have
reflections and
i'm still not thoroughly convinced that
there is no duality between a system and
its environment
right so if they're working together
perhaps these are like you know
dually in a sort of mathematical sense
um
so if if that's the case then i just
want to know are affordances like
a property of the system constructed or
conditions
um how like
do they change radically is it dynamical
nice questions the instrumentalist take
so active inference is a statistical
model that we made and it doesn't make
metaphysical claims about what systems
really can do
it's a modeling approach in that case
affordances are whatever the
investigator
puts into the model as affordances right
then the question about what the
system's affordances truly
are that's a great question it comes
back to how do systems
apparently negotiate completely new
affordances
where where was flying a plane where
does that come into play
exactly well is that part of our
extended
niche part of our constructed niche and
so we can think about that in terms of
just
the same eyesight that we had before and
the same finger movements
that we had access to before but now
it's being deployed
in a different niche so the extended
cognitive outcome
is just radically different so in the
case of tooling
and language as a tool and and usage of
instruments
potentially one could argue that it's
still the bodily affordances that are
being used
but higher order contingencies are being
learned by the system
to be able to play piano or fly a plane
so the affordance of turning the plane
left
can be still seen as moving your hand to
the left on a joystick
conditioned on an agent who understands
that their preference is to move that
way
and now has this sort of mapping between
what they do with their hand on the
joystick
and where the plane goes
but what kinds of new bodily affordances
you know can we have that's
right and they think and they take
different forms that's what's cool
blue and then anyone else with a raised
hand
so i was thinking about affordances in
relation to time
and also like in release relation to the
last math stream
when you guys were talking about how um
like when does
memory start to form right and so like
as you're looking at your reflections
in the diamond like there's you're
looking at your reflections and then
there comes a space maybe where you can
reach your reflection
i don't remember if that was exactly how
it was worded but that's like when maybe
memory starts to crystallize
something like that maybe if maybe i
butchered it do you want to step in and
correct me
no okay sorry um so then
you know i was thinking about like when
you have young kids
and they perceive time right i talked
about expansion and compression about
time a little bit earlier
so when a kid perceives time a small
child everything is
like yesterday or tomorrow right like
there's no
like concept of next week like they
don't even know what a week is right so
like you have these new affordances like
the
that come with learning right otherwise
it's just before
or next right like it's interesting and
so when do these affordances like
does that correspond to maybe the
ability to to
reach your own reflection in the
diamonds
and i flipped it here to what our
thoughts so maybe
if anyone has a thought on that what
our thoughts are yep adam and then
anyone else
but actually before i go um if shanna
wants to
speak to a blue just said i'd actually
like to hear that yeah
go for it but then i have thoughts yep
yep yeah yeah
uh okay feel free well i think it's sort
of integrated yet uh you know the
diamonds are
um um very difficult objects right that
i was thinking that could be
the perfect model i shouldn't say
perfect
a more perfect model of what's going on
um
uh with memory right so you have these
you know
cases that i always talk about uh you
know beautiful people like clive waring
who have a three-second memory from
a retrograde amnesia and so you have to
ask
someone like clyde like is he
experiencing
you know a complete temporal
non-locality
every two seconds the child right child
mind
um which i have a lot of right like for
a child what are the conditions for
object persistence right in their own
very state
you know um like with the diamond and
things like that i think you can
model what it means to have shanna
when i'm six you know and shanna when
i'm 85
or something why is it the same shanna
and i don't think it is
like at all um so when you say something
like like
memory and what are you actually looking
at so
um i'm you know again if i think there's
this duality between like the system and
its environment
um how can you actually visualize that
in this in this sort of diamond
mentality
and so the thing about the diamond right
is that if perhaps memory is some kind
of impurity
and you'll never actually get to it so
if it if a memory is like a
mineralogical impurity then you never
actually get the impurity you just get
the reflections of the whole thing
and so to sort of take what blue said
and just tighten it just a little bit
that might be more of what's actually
going on
that perhaps the mineralogical impurity
is that if maybe if you only have it now
and that if you're not able to access
all the other reflections
that are on the diamond you may not have
a future and you may not have you know
an extended time
but there's also something to say that
has that diminished
like your vibrant experience somebody
like me who's like
can really drop in can drop in very
delusion like
i am a degree of heat i am a degree of
white i am a unit of sand
his formalism is super powerful because
it's giving
um becoming an action to these
individualities these husseiites right
that somebody else would say have no
turn in the unit of consciousness or
something
so i think what i'm trying to do combine
this notion of
becoming that is individual super
individualistic like you know
i am a spoon of coconut like a spoonful
of coconut like that's it
um with this notion of this diamond
being
and they're not just reflections right
they're like pro finite reflections so
they are
um totally disconnected so that's sort
of the mess
that i'm sort of i think is like
underlying the beginnings of memory
maybe it's just this kind of pure mess
and
as you age or whatever age is sort of
involved in these pro-ital coverings and
so in the covering space
uh you know if you're working uh
through proprioception and things like
that there's a lot of work in neurology
saying that you know
your brain probably processes more
topologically if you're a child and you
only have like a now
and a bunch of points you don't really
have a lot of covering spaces right
um yeah so i think working with diamonds
which you know we'll get to in a little
bit
so i think there's something definitely
at play with you're staring at your
memories
right you're walking around in your past
like all the time so i don't ever think
you can actually get to the
true memory and if unless you reach like
the infant state again
thanks adam ben robert
so
that's to revisit the affordance issue
um
so if i'm uh understanding things
there could be in a way um you could say
like in any given moment
there's like a view from the outside
like
uh what were the what was the scope of
the possibility
of the actual interactions for the
system uh
given its configuration but because of
niche construction that's also a moving
target
but then there could be another set of
like perception of
these affordances by the system where
that perception itself
changes the affordance structure and
this can be of different variety so like
the system
and a kind of um uh dynamically self
configuration
um and like
jostling around if was doing like
implicit inference just figuring out
sussing out what the affordance
structure is and then this kind of
implicit perception
then there could be on another level
like explicit
affordance uh perception and each of
these influencing
the other and maybe operating uh
differently and across purposes
um with respect to
uh i was just
paraphrasing but trying to paraphrase
whatever and i have my own twist sign
um because this seems like a
connected this a lot of things will
connect to this um
for memory
i've been thinking of
again back to consciousness and
different forms of it
um like what do we mean
when we're accessing something again
what does it take to remember things in
different ways
and how does our different kinds of
awareness of what happened
relate to our ability to remember these
things
and so you could have a kind of memory
uh
as just a sort of like baked in on what
would they say a hysteresis a kind of
like
yeah you push in the thing and then it
through its dynamics or through it's
it's
it's it's material properties just kind
of holds the shape and you got a memory
there
of the indentation like a desire but in
terms of this like
holding onto memory like a clive wearing
type memory
and time does seem
key for contextualization and like blue
is saying about the way
time changes with age it seems like that
kind of time
and the way we construct it one of the
things you
would say like we spatialize it and we
spatialize it
relative to what probably relative to
you know
us as an agent pursuing goals in the
world with this
the inference of different affordance
structures but okay what what
what are the different ways though that
you can relate to this spatialized time
into this
uh maybe objectified you uh and then
different ways of doing this what are
the different kinds of self-reference
involved
that's a issue maybe get into later but
one of the things i'm wondering in terms
of memory
uh and this might relate to um like uh
impurities in the crystals is that the
ability of things to get entangled to
point to themselves in different ways so
like within this like three second
window
there's maybe a sequence of frames of
sense making
but there's a broader frame of sense
making of a causal unfolding
that has a certain stability over which
it can hold itself together
but part of what would let this um
specious present this um inherent
depth to to the now might be this kind
of self-reference
where um the you know earlier frames of
experience have predictive information
about what follows but then what follows
has information and points to what was
in the past the kind of
you know post-sticking the predicting
the future and post-sticking the fast
passed as part of this process of
unfolding sense-making
and it seems like the degree to which
you could do this and the ways in which
you do this
that would be the degree to which uh
things might likely
be likely to stick around that they
would be might likely to be
made uh saline to find hooks
um in this process where everything's
competing with everything to keep going
that the ability of something to get
entangled with itself in different ways
um would provide different degrees of
sticking power
um and that this would involve
um things like just you know you know
multi
modality like like like a heterogeneous
code like maybe
my uh my direct you know first person
shooter point of view uh is pointing to
like
linguistic a linguistic code or some
sort of iconic symbolization
or some sort of other like enteroceptive
intuitive code
but like these all cross cross
referencing each other that'd be like
one way of like
hooking things together but you could
also hook things together in terms of
like
an explicit causal sequence where it's
just this
to this to this that the ball kicked the
shoe the boot kicked the ball
the ball went down the ramp the mouse
got that she like the whole rube
goldberg thing that
that could be part of it too but but
actually more so if it's coherent and
maybe
agentic if it's related to
basically i think we're gonna have to
get personhood into this in the nature
of it
um relative like the causal streams that
you have the most familiarity with and
that
um fit into most of this uh
meaning-making hierarchy
that has like a visceral uh thing uh
a visceral grounding a symbolic
grounding the more of these
can come together probably the better
it'll it'll persist
and and the more that uh impurity uh
will um
give the sparkle so
thanks adam robert and then we'll
probably move to the next slide yeah
uh this slide with the thoughts i was i
wanted to say something about the parts
yeah but if you still have something
else then we you don't
okay so first of course i would be
curious how
active infants people would kind of what
they would say what the thought is or
what it means um
and just philosophically i think that's
a very interesting question
and there are certain kind of
traditional ways how we think about
thinking
and it seems to me that active inference
is challenging
some of those very traditional
assumptions but i'm not quite sure how
exactly
so the first assumption um that's the
obvious
way uh that it's kind of obvious how
active inference challenges that but the
first assumption is
and that thinking is something which um
is like a counterpart um to what's
happening physically
so in the physical world and there's
thinking which is i'm kind of opposed to
it
and i think in active inference that's
there
this dichotomy is kind of um erased um
that's kind of obvious and the second
question is
um there was a long
um there's a long tradition in thinking
about thinking which has to do
or which which says that thinking is
something which is rule based or
law like loss of thought or in a more
modern
in the more modern saying one would say
oh it's about information processing or
probabilistic reasoning or
whatever and but that seems to me to
kind of clash at least with the
phenomenological way
uh or with the phenomenology of thinking
in some sense so
thinking seems to be something direct
and unmediated and we talked about
the now um which is a particular example
of that
and i wasn't quite sure how that hangs
together with the whole active inference
um theory basically with the mathematics
of it
i mean if we as i would mainly assume
you talk about inferences processes
which are happening and defined over
some
bounded system um so that seems to lend
itself more to this
information processing view of thinking
but that seems to be
somehow opposed to the phenomenology of
thinking and i
was wondering how you kind of bring
these things together
great questions one thought might be
that
the way that we've seen things like
anxiety or affective states
be addressed in active inference is with
a parameter reflecting that
and so it's almost like there's the core
active inference model
the one that you know data comes into
and then there's this interpretive layer
and so i might say at this point that
the active inference framework doesn't
make strong claims
as to the you know what is a packet
called thought
or what is the nature of thought because
as a scale-free framework
first off there's the whole
instrumentalism realism so
it could be a totally defensible stance
active inference says nothing
about thought um or maybe somebody wants
to unpack it in a way where they think
it does
but at the first past the things that
we've seen models of active inference
about that people experience as thought
like anxiety or excitement or something
like that those are
parameters that are named in a
mathematical model
and they don't seem to make strong
claims on the nature of thought
adam what do you think about that
um so in terms of like i guess uh
the good folk and and how they relate to
thought um
this notion of it being set in a way
separable from action and distinguished
from like
this in the world uh just doing and just
acting
uh that seems like a a good
place to to work with and so if we're
talking about that it seems like it
would
relate to different species of
sophisticated inference
where you would be doing these kinds of
counter factual rollouts
of what it would be to pursue different
policies or patterns of action selection
and for me it would be
to the extent that it's conscious it
would have to be uh
uh grounded out as some sort of embodied
simulation
i want to build everything out of action
perception cycles
and everything out of sensory motor
things that i can ultimately that's
going to be the grounding that'll be the
experience
um that's not to say that thought would
only be determined by
what you simulated in your rollout for
instance like you could have
a lot of um spreading semantic
association
of just like a kind of priming effect
and then words come to mind that that's
part of it and that's not necessarily
like
something you're controlling in terms of
pursuing a policy that's just happening
or some sort of um association again
with interception of just like
a kind of resonance in your body that
might play into and parameterize
this process but the thinking it seems
like it would be
a mode of sophisticated inference of
generating these counter factual
possibilities and using them for things
like
um different kinds of causal reasoning
um
different ways of um situating
what you think is happening or could
happen
sometimes and that's how i would relate
to thought i think
i don't know if the like what do we want
from thought we want more
and so that might help great question
and do we want
to experience the phenomenology of human
thought which is an uncultured phenomena
or
are we trying to talk about trees and
all kinds of other things so everyone
awesome thanks for the raised hand
blue shauna robert
i think shawna was first so all the
french yep go for it
oh okay awesome yeah just a couple
things um
you know just like daniel was saying
when we say thought
right so i'm i mean you know i
you know it's i don't think thought is
like recognition of a truth and a
proposition
i'm of the mindset you know that uh
i think kierkegaard said like all
thought as a self-repeating false
sororities
which yeah it's like so i'm not of the
sense that thought is logic
or anything like that because there's
first order logic second order logic and
it's just you know you can get
uh like what is pro finite thought so i
really think we need to actually when we
say what our thoughts we need to say
like what do we mean
by thought right so robert and i have
this model of like
in awareness so it could be that the
level of your awareness you know
dictates
the levels of time you have and then
also what these thoughts are
so you know someone can say oh a rock
has no thought but perhaps the
the units of thought of the rock are
just lower than our units of perception
something like that so i think it's very
strong to say that things
do not have thought right so to ask like
what a thought is
it's interesting also to say what is not
a thought you know
so you know i have these um kind of you
know interesting ideas like if you can
model the brain as this
you know protel sheath in a perfectoid
space which is what this diamond is
then if you can actually model neurons
as you know these
points in the diamonds these
mathematical impurities that are
actually
morphisms of schemes and you would say
that okay thoughts are these morphisms
but we know thoughts are a little more
messy than just satisfying strict
associativity
and up to conditions so the math can
only give you a model of the thing
because perhaps it's not strictly
associative so i mean we all know that
you do have a
sodium potassium like channel like kind
of neurotransmitter cluster network
happening
you always want it to be springtime in
your head you would not want like a
winter
um in your head where all the synapses
and the trees die and things but nobody
can tell you how the trees in your head
sort of photosynthesized
so i know after i gave that first talk
someone asked you know well what are
actually
thoughts so again if these neurons are
these geometric points and i still think
the brain is some sort of non-local
hologram
sort of thing the its ability to rewire
is profound
you also don't want to get injured right
because there is a detrimental effect
um but so like how do you sustain
this sort of you know uh temporal
non-locality inside this pro-finite
condition
maybe robert and i are under this with
this sort of in levels of awareness
if you're able to achieve sort of
simulta simultaneous states of
awareness then perhaps you could
probably get out of the idea of thought
is the truth of a proposition
and then maybe you could try to probably
figure out what that is again i'm not
convinced that we're
doing anything new um like what a new
thought
is i'm not really sure what that is um
or if you can actually like you say
scale free
right so scale free would be able to for
us to make this in awareness
sort of phenomena and um so i agree with
robert i'm not sure if there's a
contention there between the
phenomenology of what is thought and
then
the sort of perception of like what
thought is again
really tricky to see you know but real
thought is getting new connections
you know and then it's like okay what
new connections in my same interface
like not really sure how that is
so i'm glad active imprints allows for
like new but i'm not sure if it's like
radically new i'm not sure if any of us
would be able to recognize something
radically new
you know um okay i'll stop there nice
thank you more is different blue and
then robert then adam
so just so i was like gonna piggyback
off of your point and get into that so
and and then i have a question so really
my background is neuroscience and so
when you look at like the brain the
fundamental unit of a thought
like has to come from the action
potential right like the sodium and
potassium and
whatever that is happening but like not
one action potential makes a thought
so so like you were talking about
um how do you measure emergence and you
know there's like the critical
criticality hypothesis right so like a
certain number
of action potentials could lead to a
thought perhaps
but but how do you quantify emergency
without a counter
object right and so you said you kept
saying this and so i'm going to maybe
ask you to clarify
or push on this a little bit because
account objects like when i think of a
counter i think about a counter in terms
of computer programming
for i you know from 0 to 50 count count
count count
so is it like counting the number of
action potentials or the number of ants
leaving pheromone traces or the number
of pheromones dropped right so
so when you think about a counter object
is that what you mean by a counter
object or is there some
fundamental thing that i'm missing i
don't think i ever said the word counter
object so can you tell me where i said
that
yeah it's so talki it was when you were
quantifying emergence
and i took some notes so you have
built-in
emergence is built into the system
versus having a counter
so maybe not counter objects but you
said oh yeah it wasn't
yeah it wasn't um not an index right
so i'm not i'm not of the why does i
have to start at one you know so
i don't think real numbers exist so that
you're that's it's a bunch of
equivalence classes
so just pretty much well 50 of these
things happened i don't really know what
that means
right but i agree with you that how do
you actually quantify emergence because
right if you have too much
hypersynchronous activity you have a
seizure and a seizure is not a thought
right everyone
so it seems to be that there is and
that's what chris fields and i and
everyone are after is like what is this
stop mechanism
the stop mechanism that you can have you
need a clustering happening in the
neurons right to
actually have bot thought doesn't seem
to come out of your elbow
but if the if the nervous system is
non-local like i believe it is
um which is why i'm an advocate for the
active inference of the you know
embodied cognition
if the neural system is non-local and
nobody's proved that it's not
um then how do you actually say
when the amount of clustering gives you
like look at all this our synapses are
bright and perfect and leaves and
everything is like beautiful in here
right um and effortlessly
how does it come how does thought come
so effortless
right sometimes and then but if you have
too much
firing then you don't get it and it's
not like the
you know there's a an actual rest in the
action potential like um blue what's the
order of neuron firing
what are you smaller than nanometers at
that point between firing
it has to be right it's not plank scale
it's not like 10 to the negative 42 but
it's small
right and so with that kind of time
happening i'm just
i'm perplexed you have so many layers of
time happening neuronal firing time like
stem cell firing time you know so um
when i said counter i don't think i
wasn't referring to um like
um um an actual yeah when i
yeah well i i think i was saying counter
as in most people just
take time to be some kind of geiger
counter
and there's no emergence like at all you
know hope i answered that and didn't
make it worse
yeah so i couldn't tell i couldn't
figure out if you're like trying to talk
about like a counter factual
like the opposite of emergence like
what's the opposite of emergency or if
you're talking about a counter like
you know when you sum things up so
that's what it would be
yeah great
um robert and adam you want to go to the
next one or do you want to continue on
the thought
up to you well i i just had a very quick
uh clarification
of my question actually adam can reply
immediately after that's good
because adam said something like what do
we want the theory of thought
to be or what do we want it for which
kind of thought are we
are we talking when i was asking my
question about the nature of thought i
was
mainly thinking about conscious thought
um i mean there's this tradition that
this which says something like oh the
mind is whatever the brain does and then
you talk about
i don't know um potentials about firing
about
calcium and i i don't know what and and
and if you then say okay well that's a
very abstract thing and you call that
thought
um i think that's fine it's fine and one
but it doesn't really
um give you a good answer to what you
mean with conscious thought
and the standard way how psychologists
normally answer that question is to say
okay well there is this unconscious
processing happening
and then something magically happens and
that turns into conscious thought
i wasn't quite clear whether predictive
processing or
or active inference or whatever frame
you want to
take really answers that question or
whether the
whether it says oh it's actually not a
good question and
kind of dissolves this question and well
that's a bit more specific about my
question
adam go for it
try to tie a few things together um so
yeah so what we want from thought and
what our sensibilities might be
and that they'll what boundaries we
establish for where
we find it and don't that'll be what
relative to what what do we want
but to try to like build up um so
i think there is a sense in what you
could say like it's like
a rock is a mind or
is thought even though it's of extremely
dumb variety
it's action uh because we can point to
it
it's a kind of density um and that
it's you can think of it as uh you know
it's just gonna probably
unlike like a crystal which can grow it
was just sort of like it can do one
thing which is steadily degrade over
time
on some kind of entropic gradient but to
the extent it doesn't
that's that's all that's the
intelligence it's got but then we get to
systems that can like
actually um through sophisticated
dynamics
uh start to do things like uh
suss out different things that can
happen and do a kind of a
more flexible policy selection and they
might be potentially
in in order to do this they might have
to be critically organized
and that that's the only thing that
could allow for generalized evolution or
generalized bayesian model selection
that you actually have to be
poised at this like inter regime in
order to have the right properties in
order
to have um both uh the variation where
you can suss out the possibilities
but also the the stability uh um
you're not pouring over into chaos or
disorder
uh that you can actually build structure
upon structure so it seems like that's
going to be
critical um in terms of
like if we're talking about something
like and it's like
so we're talking about something like
you know a life form maybe that's like
some people say like that's kind of like
like
this sort of more sophisticated
mentality
that um with um you know optionality
maybe that's like the hallmark of life
maybe this sort of
hierarchical nested modeling if some of
these
inner loop processes are capable of
bifurcating in different ways and giving
you a kind of
like intelligent optionality uh maybe
you know
that's a kind of thumb but let's keep
working up um so
if we're talking about something uh like
the brain
i would think of like a
a hierarchy of uh
nested coupling processes evolving on
different time scales and
uh in the community they'll tend to call
these things a non-equilibrium study
state densities
i call them self-organizing harmonic
modes and it's a way i interpret
neural synchrony um to the degree that
you get it it's
facilitating communication through
coherence uh making sure that
um within these systems not just like
tuning an excitation inhibition balance
to
and then it works but that to actually
within this maelstrom
to get um coherent dynamics coherent
inference uh
you would you you need the neurons need
to team up
so you need synchrony you need synchrony
for um
i guess what they would call a marginal
message passing so it'd be like
marginalization like a joint belief and
then you packet your beliefs and these
like coalitions
are doing like like these units it's
quantitization of sense making
of prediction error and prediction and
so there would be like this nested
hierarchy
and so if you're talking about something
like uh let's say like gamma
frequency that might be like a very
small local unit of like synchrony and
sense making and
maybe that's like a a quantization of
like prediction error that will be
passed upwards
um so that's like an observation uh
within the scope of this gamma packet
though
maybe that's like a prediction for like
whatever is inside it but
you keep going up so then maybe that's
something like beta and then
you know so gamma like 40 times a second
and then beta would be something like uh
you know
maybe high and low or use the terms like
somewhere between 13 to 30 times a
second
and maybe you're starting to get like uh
uh it depends where you're at but you
these higher order attractors
and these higher order predictions like
like uh like a
composition like something like a hand
reaching something like that
but like where's consciousness gonna
come into this and why
uh it seems if you can take these
different
um recognition these these
recognition of different patterns and
you can stitch them together
such that you have uh within the
organizing principle of
i would suggest an egocentric
perspective of a particular point of
view
and you can arrange them in some kind of
space what kind of coherence how much
that's a good question
some kind of time some kind of cause of
relation
well now this inference
you might start to say well now you
might be inferring a world
specifically a structured world model
with spatial temporal and causal
properties where things can unfold and
you can have something like
a stream of experience if this
synchronization manifold is basically
giving you a joint belief
over your sensorium and so it seems like
alpha
is the frequency where you can get a big
enough of a
agreement of a negotiated agreement
making that you could bring together all
the different embodied causes
pegged by an egocentric reference frame
in terms of anatomy and like
what would be a scope and something that
i might say that's implicit is
there's this inverse relationship there
seems between
the frequency at which you can get um
oscillations or harmonics and the scope
of what can be synchronized so
you can get like a little thing to agree
really quickly but to get a big thing
it's going to necessarily take more time
and so more things can come into the mix
and consciousness i'm wondering if that
is basically
at a scope where you're doing these
joint estimates
of system world states that let you both
inform
and be informed by evolving action
perception cycles
but actually the the functional closure
that you achieve for this estimation
and if you're having these things
brought together in a way that gives you
a point of view of some kind
well i might say okay now it's something
like conscious thought
this stream of experience doing
different things
um where but the thinking part of it we
might want to
save that or not for something like
uh imaginative planning or some sort of
like counter like like
you're you're thinking of something
other than what is and that's actually
what's happening at this intermediate
level
where you're conscious but you're
sussing out different possibilities
as you're trying to situate something in
some sort of
coherent spatial temporal unfolding that
you can make sense of
um and so the idea would be like
everything that we can think of
we're necessarily temporalizing and
spatializing
just so we can grok it like rocket i
mean literally so we can
bring it into some sort of relation with
this intermediate level
embodied simulation otherwise we can't
think of anything
but i'd say there could be a kind of
unconscious thought also
this actually might lead to something
like a counter i think you get one
counter
in that this bundling there's a certain
time set which you can get
a big enough of a coalition there's a
time frame for achieving that
in some ways that's that's a kind of
counter that's a kind of like
discretization and you might think of
this in terms and like uh
and active inference is like kind of
discrete updating of the generative
model
um the but it seems like you can get
something like
unconscious thought potentially uh via
the hippocampal system to kind of
loop around the clive wearing again um
and that
one way i would think of thought as as
generalized or navigation through
generalized space
hitting a particular not arbitrary
target
being able to find your way there and so
i've been working with these uh
roboticists who are um building these
slam systems they're
i mean the simultaneous localization and
mapping and so
uh what these robots are doing they're
trying to figure out where am i
in this environment what is the sense of
this environment and they're doing this
actively in terms of they're they're
moving around
you know uh scouting out what's
happening and there's this like mutually
concerning influence of what is this
world i'm in
and where am i and what is this world
and where am i and figuring this out but
this uh core system uh
would seem to have uh within it
uh these place fields these like
locations that could be
in physical space like the tree is there
i'm here
my you know my kitchen's down there but
it could also be within a conceptual
space
and so um they're sometimes modeled as
like bump attractors
where like you get these like local
recurrences within this like
centrally located thing and
basically this chaining of these bump
attractors would
then chain together broader dynamics for
the rest of the brain
and so in theory this could operate um
in a way where you're
not aware of it it's like coordinating
sense making and a kind of i wouldn't
say it's a propositional but in like a
an orderly way there's like a topology
to it
and you went from here to here to here
to here so in theory
um that could bypass consciousness i
don't know if it can or not
but this in terms of this nested graphs
of graphs of graphs
there could also be a kind of holography
there potentially
in terms of um
well not wholeheartedly um non-locality
let me say not holography non-locality
there
um in terms of when you
coarse grain uh at some level of course
screening
uh locality falls away i'm not sure
about that
but uh yeah so there's some thoughts on
thought but one more thing though
so ultimately i think this is going to
be crucial
uh understanding the the principles
underlying this system not the system in
a narrow sense
but of this graphs of graphs of graphs
this where these inner loop processes
have these different capabilities
um it will be the secret to uh advanced
intelligence
understand like what do we want from
thought and cognition and i also suspect
it will be the answer to schroedinger's
question and that
what would make um i think life
clever and more than a whirlpool like
you can so dissipative systems they can
be extremely
impressive extremely life-like but this
sort of
inner loop process that can give you
this sort of optionality
that this potentially a critically
organized inner loop process
that can bind together overall dynamics
and get the overall system
because of this bifurcating potential
this sort of optionality
um that's going to be important now what
if then
this inner loop system is also a kind of
counter
or a kind of like thing that stitches
itself together where
basically like genetic inheritance like
it gives you
over over time the ability to basically
um get better priors into it better um
it lets you
lets you transfer learn it lets you what
happens here
and influence the next thing can
influence the next thing and so this
could be a way of what we
you could think of um uh jablonka i
think i'm
ruining the name but like this unlimited
associative learning as like a hallmark
of consciousness
this kind of like transition something
like that though this unlimited
learning open-ended learning
as phylogeny as basically an inner loop
process
capable of coordinating the overall
system which has
um some by some sort of like pointer
relation some sort of semantic pointers
semantics which itself is um
allows for a kind of heredity a kind of
a kind of inheritance
of whatever happened and so i think we
bring in those two things together an
inner
loop process capable of some kind of
counter factual processing
and uh link that to inheritance
now we'll have what we need to have um
either life or a potentially conscious
system
thank you adam i flip to the next
slide on diamonds and
holographs where does this come into
play it's not something that you'd find
in the active inference literature
today but maybe it will be found there
tomorrow why
calling on our diamond experts
yeah yeah are we bypassing the dichronic
synchronic
either yep wherever you want to go on
this slide
yes okay okay yeah so um
you know so again if we're if you know
like robert is saying okay
is the mind what the brain does like
what is this what do we want from font
when you're when we're generating um you
know in the
like pro adversarial kind of or in a you
know generative adversarial network you
have this generator talking to you know
um you know the you know
like itself saying no no no this is a
cat this is not a cat and it's sort of
this ai is talking to itself
um what what is that in us when we're
sort of talking to ourself
so again you have someone like me in the
category theory side saying okay
i do think there is some kind of strong
duality between the agent and its
environment
so if you if if minds
are modeled in this diamond way right
then what you're actually doing is just
sort of engaging with your reflections
right how do you actually engage with
your reflections do your reflections
have your reflections so
kind of based on what adam are saying
it's like what's the role of priors
in holography what does it actually mean
to sort of have um
that was my original question when an
agent is figuring out how to jump over a
wall it's never seen before
um how is it doing that what if
affordances
are just a set of parameters that are
built into the thing
right so let's try to do this and uh if
you could do this parameter free
what would that model actually look like
so for someone like me i am fascinated
how when i speak to you the speech
doesn't last
doesn't last doesn't last doesn't last
but somehow you remember what i say
remember what i say you must probably
construct a hologram
holographic copy of of me and what i'm
saying
so that you store that somehow so
someone like me with almost like a total
recall
can remember stuff like this i know i
can talk to people and i have seven
different versions of time going on
you know um how do you align like all of
those seven and you're just focusing on
like on what's happening now so um you
aren't
really so you have a crazy feedback
processing going on
um and none of this is happening in real
time right because there's neural
transmitters happening so this is
already
the past all of this uh whatever that
means when we say the past and so i'm
just wondering what the
you know when you have a very strict set
of priors governing how your agent
behaves
where do those come into play and how do
those work if the very way that the
agent
operates is through holography so again
holography is like you have a
you know some kind of dimensional
relation going on that perhaps you know
we have a 2d retina for a 3d creature
2d retina is taking an information and
compressing it and then
reconstructing it in a higher way so um
that's just for that i have this model
of you know instead of just having the
normal holographic principle which
relates anti-disinterest
theory um i'm trying to get it in sort
of a diamond way where you actually use
the um
italic homology of diamonds which are
these funkers or computers
and uh build up a holography from
an image functor of sheaves so it's
purely mathematical let's just build up
a holographic space
from you know image functors which is
really
uh relevant to active inference because
you're acting you're acting you're
acting or acting there's no other
definition than a functor than
some kind of relation so building up
holography
from relations uh and the conformal
aspect which is the metric free
sort of gravity free space would be in
the pro finite condition of the diamonds
so you have a six function formalism
which is replacing anti-sitter space
you have a pro-finite condition which is
replacing the gravity free
so that seems to me like a a very um
interesting way to figure out how an
agent is navigating
if you know there are reflections so you
know the math part aside
just what is you know the active
inference experts here
think about engaging with your
reflections that it's never really
anything new
you're just sort of walking around in
your echo space
thanks for the comment there adam and
then anyone else with a raised hand
so this might not
doc but let's try um
in terms of like the nature of like how
would i
remember shanna or and
how can i know anyone or anything um i'm
wondering if it always has to be
through some kind of um generalized
mirroring with
your own embodied experience and
ultimately it's got to be cashed out
that way
and that this the na the particular
nature of like the the holography in
terms of the ability to like
reconstitute and you know reducing the
dimensions and then
expanding them again um would be
by virtue of um you
having this system which would just uh
through a variety of reasons be able to
generate intelligent coupling with the
world of a sensory motor variety
but also run this same process in a
in an offline mode so that you can
imagine you know
body simulation and that if
you then um so this the inactive
inference this
uh the sensory motor processes
are understood as these self-realizing
predictions
where you'll set these equilibrium
points and then this hierarchy
will just sort of reconfigure and unfold
and as it's jostling around
and passing these implicit predictions
and predictions around
it just dynamically or just it'll
by by hamilton's principal police action
as like
waterfront hill it'll find this minimal
state
of minimal prediction error that it's
ultimately cached on reflex arcs in the
world
but for thought would be um the
virtualization of that so you're
imagining this pattern of reaching out
so you have this
um construction system in this virtual
reality system
and then if there's a reliable patterns
of coherent state transitions that i am
likely to do in different circumstances
well now i'm starting to get like an
agent model of myself well it's a real
of a kind and you're sharing it if
there's a reliable
set of policies that will happen in
different circumstances it's like okay
well it's self-reflective though it
seems we're gonna have to um
objectify the cell somehow and i'm
thinking this likely comes
through mirroring actually through
relationships between parents and
children
at first and that you're um
and where the parents seem to be
actually soliciting some people say the
mirroring is nate i actually don't think
it is
it seems like parents uh helped to
solicit it
um but the they mirror with you so that
you learn to mirror
and so that creates the learning
curriculum but through this um
these games played between caretaker and
child
uh you learn to get this mapping between
what's out there
and what's here somewhere along the way
you'll
learn to basically associate
um what other people are doing in any
ways even if you're not like you'll
learn just to mirror with them they're
over there and then you see that and you
draw this analogy to your own
embodiment your own you put yourself in
the same pose the same situation
uh and then this now gives you a basis
for a kind of objectified selfhood
it's still always from like this uh
egocentric perspective but
now you're able to like get this other
person and i'm thinking that that's like
this kind of interface for like
my shanna model would have to be like
the
the docking point would be something
like this uh
this third person objectified selfhood
which then would let you
cash it out or unpack it
in an embodied coherent body simulation
something like that
one thought about like again setup
and discriminators it seems like that uh
that might be again crucial for
uh both hard problems and uh
stranger questions i think um there's
this
one uh thinker he's this uh
academic psychiatrist a rucker did you
plan on having him on daniel or
he wrote this one he's fantastic
actually i think that'll be a good idea
so but it's this idea of like so
a system uh basically
um he calls it like uh allostatic
overload and a collapse model
where basically through these systems we
have these functional bottlenecks
these bottlenecks will tend to kind of
that are
helping to establish the synchronization
manifold over a system that the
coordination
that these heavily trafficked and
contingent
areas will tend to fail first when you
stress the system too much
and so uh and this would give you like
for instance a kind of flexible
hierarchy or either you're doing things
maybe on like unconsciously but just
like fast feedback loops of the
environment you're not getting fancy
you know quick in the dead or you're
letting yourself build
models upon models reflection upon
reflection but that these more rare five
things
they'll fail first and so you got this
like
you can move up and down in
sophistication but um i'm wondering
whether
in terms of uh and so this would apply
not just to
all intelligent all interesting
intelligence systems is the claim
but while you have this like natural
kind of adjustment of your
sophistication
i'm wondering if it could be good to
have something
that preemptively anticipates this so
you're not just
having reactive regime collapses where
it's actually
you can actually like you know maybe not
yeah i could switch to an unconscious
berserker mode right now maybe i don't
want to be in that position
and so if i can get something that's
like giving me a read on
my degree of like stress of allostatic
load of the degree of like
how how close am i to the edge um that
could be a good thing and so for
the brain this would appear to be
largely the interior cingulate would be
probably the main
uh free energy or prediction error
integrator
it's uh centrally located it um
has like in every sense it's like boom
got the most connectivity and it's just
perfectly suited to say like
how well are you doing in
self-evidencing i'm wondering like
within
cells if you have a similar kind of
gan-like discriminator
um some sort of like inner metabolic
cycle that like accumulates i know like
maybe like mitochondria accumulating
like radicals
or like some sort of like gene
expression loop i don't know but
something like this
that's highly central that like when it
starts to go
this would then influence your policy
selection this would then
influence your orchestration i don't
know what that would look like in a cell
but for the brain this appears to be um
there's does appear to be some fairly
centralized structures
literally that allow for that kind of
gan-like function
and that is key to any to basically
intelligent agency
um and and is also key for things
potentially like um uh
uh i don't know if i believe this
actually so sam gershman has argued this
is like
um reality monitoring like a higher
order thought sense
um that i think something like that
could work but but the idea is that you
know how do i distinguish if i just
imagine something or if i actually
experienced it
and that there is some sort of like dan
like discriminator he treats the whole
frontal lobes like this
um uh that that's something else but
it seems like this though gan framework
though this idea of discriminators
is extremely flexible extremely powerful
and will apply across a broad range of
systems
i think is actually really essential so
yeah thanks adam
to bring it back to act infant the
diamond holograph
i kind of drew two diamond shapes on my
page
one was person a and person b and their
shared informational niche
they're both looking at a whiteboard and
so there's two people
communicating to the shared screen and
unpacking and that was something we
talked about with chris fields
and then to relate it to this diacronic
through time and
synchronic at the same time i kind of
thought about like a bow tie
or two diamonds where in the current
moment is the agent
now and then there's the agent in the
future
at a inferred trajectory point and then
also in the past
so we're sort of like retrodicting we're
now casting and we're also predicting
the future
and maybe the pathway through the past
present future it's like a narrative
that helps the organism make sense of
where it is at that time
um any other points on diamonds or i
think we can kind of go to the
future and give okay awesome our closing
thoughts and awesome you know anyone
who's watching live can add a thought or
we can
go around here as well what is the
future of active inference or a future
or a direction
where do we see this field in the future
10 years from now or
some other time point out will we
be adapting active inference to
high-level unsupervised
learning will we merge
with strong artificial intelligence and
where do we see
embodied cognition scaling two are
applying to
[Music]
blue and then robert and then anyone
else
why don't you go ahead yeah yeah well
sure thanks um so just my personal
opinion it would be very interesting to
see
and to what extent active inference
would or could move from i think now a
lot of discussions are kind of
mechanistic
i mean complicated mechanisms which are
happening in the brain or in a cell or
wherever i would be very interested
whether that
where the active inference could be a
way of
precisely speaking about norms
normativity
i think someone mentioned at the very
beginning about
said something about normativity what i
mean with that is the
the distinction between infer inferring
what is the case
or focusing on what is the case what
physical stuff is going on
and what should go on in philosophy
there is this famous distinction that
one could not be derived from the other
it goes back to david hume the odd from
is it's a problem and i was wondering
whether active inference could be
could be an interesting middleway here
and the second related thought is
um which has to do with with ai and
reinforcement learning we mentioned that
in the very beginning
that symptom seems to me to be a good
i mean one could be very critical and
could say well
in some sense active inference that's
very nice and interesting and one could
do nice biology with it
um but it's not so obvious what what the
benefit would be
over compared to reinforcement paradigms
and um if one would be able to
say something reasonable to this
normativity
question then i think that's very that
would be a very big
um big plus point for active inference
but that's why i hope
that i kind of see in the future and
work which goes more into that direction
as well
thank you robert blue
so robert just to kind of respond to
that i don't know if you've seen the um
scaling active inference paper that we
looked at
um it's it's been a while um but it did
yeah number eight uh who is the first
author i forget all the chance
oh alex jones of course so um
but he definitely compared active
inference and a computational paradigm
to
uh reinforcement learning so i don't
know if you've seen that work
um and you know in different testing
different paradigms the hopper and the
the car and the hills and it was a nice
picture
anyway um so where i would really like
to see active inference in ten years
uh i mean we talked about how active
inference is
scale-free a scale-free model um
so theoretically it should also be
multi-scale
i think that there's a little bit we
have a little bit of work to do
to get it to be multiscale so and i
think that that work
definitely centers around emergence when
does the next
scale emerge when does the collection of
cells become a tissue
when does the collection of tissues
become an organ etc
so i would really like to see active
inference incorporate a bi-directional
information flow that was talked about
in krakow's paper the information theory
of individuality
i would like to see that merge with
active inference and
give us a way to talk about
how the cells in my toe
constitute me in the society that i live
in right so
nice shawna then adam
yeah blue that's great i totally agree
and support you there
um i am you know obviously a heavy
advocate of mirror phenomena
so while there may not be mirror neurons
i mean which i hope there are there is a
mirror
so i'm an advocate not just for
reinforcement but for imitative learning
so what i would like to see um
active inference move towards is a new
mathematic like a
you know adding to the mathematical
framework just some new notions so
in that the other math stream i talked
about condensed sets what are p
which are peter tulsa and dulce like
idea of shapes over points so if we
could actually get time
to be modeled as singular which i think
sounds catastrophic but it might be more
apropos to what's happening here instead
of
assuming it's continuous or a fluid that
you move through whatever that is
so if you can reframe things and
condense sets this would actually
help us incorporate this mirror
phenomena so
um you know adam and i really think the
gan network is going to be really nice
so i have this idea of constructing this
pro-generative adversarial network and
and having a perceptron that's an actual
v
stack so the stack is just a higher
notion of the diamond
so um whereas you take you know you glue
together certain pectoid spaces and you
get a diamond you can also
gather diamonds and get this v stack so
i'm
i'm interested in this phenomenon but if
we can actually take a general
adversarial network and make a pro
version of it
so then this would become like a certain
pro object in
the category of all possible generative
adversarial networks
so the goal here is to categorify
embodiment
for ai um which i think is
very strong so then you can model the
perceptron as this v-stack
perceptron so that the output
is hopefully some kind of condensed set
it's not just a
function anymore it's going to be either
like a sheaf of things
or it's going to be a whole categories
of something so this
this pro formalism would also be a model
of
um embodied meta learning so i'm an
advocate through this mirror form of
formalism to get meta learning going
which is going to reframe the frame
problem
in terms of condensed sets or category
so i think the frame problem is huge and
together categorify it would actually be
like really nice
so if you can actually model inactive
robots as advanced ai
in this kind of pro finite formalism and
you could model mirror neurons as these
imitative you know this play imitation
emulation
gans and a sort of mirror game theory
for inactive neurons this is what i
think active inference formalism can
actually do because you're you could
actually construct a correspondence
between
embodied cognition in this pro in like
my profinite formalism
and computability and sort of pro
version
of the synchronic and diacronic
emergence but have that already
built in to the pro gan so if
like diacronic and synchronic emergence
could be built in as affordances
i think that's that's really nice
because i think i think active inference
needs to have something like there's
something about the synchronic emergence
about it being
sort of higher level phenomena being you
know um
you know supervening you know on like
these
you know subvenian neural structures to
get this vertical emergence but then you
also have this sort of
horizontal emergence where it's like
wait you know um
the novel property that emerged over
time like
existed prior to emergent so i think
emergence is going to be really
beautiful and so i think if we can
incorporate
the gam approaching some kind of concept
in a higher like scaling up when we say
scale three let's also not be afraid to
scale
things like the perceptron and
affordances and
inactive robotics thanks
when you're talking about the generative
adversarial neural network i wondered if
there was like a collaborative one
just two networks that were teaching
each other helpful examples and then
when you pull back
a level even if it's framed in an
adversarial context between
two models it's actually being done in a
collaborative
sense so that kind of is almost that
multi-scale emergence right there
let's talk about the category of the gam
it's like let's have gans talking to
each other
that's what i want awesome daniel adam
well with respect to what you were just
saying daniella i think that's actually
a
potentially a really good model of play
in terms of this like
ultimately benevolent adversarial
attempted adversarially attacking
yourself
um but
yeah in terms of future directions uh
you know many things i'm not thinking of
but the things that would
particularly interest me would be um
getting actually meta learning that
would be really quite key and different
forms of metal learning
the ability to build up the
sophistication
and to have across episodes in context
actually making sure that what's
inferred and learned there
will update and so uh it seems to me
that
to help with that uh maybe
more crosstalk with machine learning
that could be useful
and more crosstalk with um uh
people like shanna who can give us like
the precision of of knowing
you know uh which mappings are legit
and what and what are our mappings
actually doing um
so for instance like i have notions that
for instance you could think of the
brain as a whole as a kind of like vegan
of sorts where it's like you have the
very variational
um auto encoder doing this
dimensionality reduction getting into
this latent space
this latent space has a kind of graph
structure like a graph neural network
that has like
geometric deep learning happening within
it and then on top of this like
the hippocampal system would give you
like a kind of a higher order semantics
on top of that
but is that legit um and
what's the relation and from there like
there's gonna be particular
operations happening some of which would
correspond potentially to things like
experience
so is your experience a kind of discreet
updating of like snapshots or is it
actually a continuous flow
um what are the like is it like for
instance within like the association
cortex like the latent space is just
like
fast message passing there or is it like
the enslavement of the whole hierarchy
so the question is like what
computational objects
are we dealing with it seems like we're
going to need crosstalk with
um people who have expertise and things
like category theory and machine
learning to actually understand those
well and i think if we bring those
together a lot of the debates might end
up being resolved like we can have for
instance
both instrumentalism and realism we can
then
at certain points start to have enough
constraints so we can
work our way um towards uh
things like uh applying sophisticated
inference to yourself
in ways that are like uh i don't want to
criticize active inference
but it does seem like sometimes a
failure mode is the power of the
framework
can result in kind the same failures
good old-fashioned cognitive science
of like don't bother me with plumbing
functionalism
and ideally if we can go across the more
perspectives we can
bring to bear on something going across
implementational algorithmic
and computational and cross-reference
them and
bring in phenomenology too that would be
really helpful and so
sometimes it seems like we're a little
bit anemic on the implementation
uh we're squinting a bit um more than we
might realize and
so how do we beef up the algorithms uh
so ultimately though for me uh the end
game
uh is i think i want to bring active
inference to
explain consciousness i think it's a
major transition in evolution
it's the elephant in the room it is the
room by and large it's not the only
thing going on but you know
we should not underestimate its power no
matter how much it's fashionable to
denigrate it
um things like the nature of selfhood as
constructed process
and getting metacognition out of that
and not just reducing metacognition
to a kind of hyperparameter but actually
as a process
with particular epistemics that are
realized in particular ways
constructively and
of that kind and then ultimately uh what
i would like
so i i think active inference will be
capable
of making major inroads into answering
schroeder's question more than we've
done in the past
i think we might even have a definitive
answer
and maybe in the not too distant future
i think we might have a definitive
answer
potentially or not to the hard problem
and ultimately i want um free will to be
a part of it
i want and by free will i know there's a
lot of ways that that's
uh word is used but actually use it i
like refer back to the language
we want the the degrees of freedom and
the directed drive
we want this optionality this
empowerment of our options being open
but we want those options
to be able to steer in particular ways
and
this like free will is like what
meaningful power is
what uh it's what enables meaning
this um it's what enables open-ended
evolution
of a particular directed kind where
we're actually getting
teleology we're actually having you know
the things we care about
and the things that actually move the
world and uh
you know that let let us let us get to
the moon
you know bombs that leveled cities all
these things
uh that the future will depend on uh
free will is going to be part of that
story precisely operationalizing what we
mean you could just say agency
that's fine but that's we're going to
need and so something like
uh and and potentially again framework
would be part of that
how well am i doing precisely narrowing
down the micro mechanics of agency
thanks that's mike thanks adam
i would love to see and expect
and will enact policy to improve
communication and education
you're right there's so much more to be
done it's worthwhile to
criticize or to see where it could
improve because those are the
affordances
for a contribution so it would be
awesome to see
everything that people just mentioned
arise as well as to include a lot of
voices in the
conversation that maybe know about
active inference today but don't feel
like
they're in a position to contribute even
beginners especially contribute through
their questions and for those who have
disciplinary
expertise or who want to be a new kind
of generalist
for this new way of doing science i hope
they'll find a home
in active inference as well so
fun times the math stream's always a
wild ride
um we really appreciate it
it's an awesome convo i hope that people
will
stay in touch if you're watching in
replay leave a comment and the lab will
still be there
and for all of you here just thanks so
much for participating and
each of you would be awesome to give a
solo or have a conversation to
explore some of these ideas so it's
great times everyone
bye okay everyone bye